hey guys I'm Abby char welcome to Abby's
kitchen and today I'm in the kitchen
with my friend Candice from edgy veg
hello so Candice you are a youtuber
superstar if you haven't checked out her
YouTube channel you have got to go there
right now and you have just released a
cookbook I did it's right here
weird huh strange yes it's called the
edgy veg 138 carnivore fruit vegan
recipes it's like the vegan cookbook for
people that aren't vegan I love that
because you guys know I'm not officially
vegan but I do cook a lot of vegan food
because it's really awesome it's so
simple to do
and of course has some really great
health benefits as well so we're gonna
be making two beautiful vegan soups tell
us about what you're gonna be making on
your channel I'm going to be making a
pumpkin sage soup which is really like
hearty and delicious and perfect for
helpful that is here really for you guys
who are in the warmer states or areas of
the world
lucky you yeah we hate you right now but
regardless we're gonna be warming up
with that soup so I'm gonna making a
roasted cauliflower and chickpea sulu
that sounds really tasty yes so I'm
super excited and hungry for these vegan
soups so let's do this let's do it
okay so Candace we are gonna start by
roasting off some vegetables and
chickpeas so you want to pop those guys
on this tray I've just taken a can here
of chickpeas that are rinsed and drained
and dried as well as possible because
that's gonna remove a lot of the excess
moisture so you can get nice and crisp
aid and then we've got a cauliflower
here that we've cut into small little
florets I'm gonna put a little bit of
olive oil on each thanks girl
yeah let's toss them up I'll do a little
salt and pepper season those bad boys
it's I know I know I love that he's
super I get that that's like super
delish all right so these are looking
good we're gonna pop these into a 450
degree oven for it the chick peas will
take about 30-40 minutes so they're nice
and crispy the cauliflower probably
about 20 minutes or so great looks so
nice and crispy so now we've got our
roasted veg we are going to make the
soup and I've got a little pot here with
some olive oil going down you can use
coconut oil or any other kind of
vegetable oil totally works
got a onion all right so I'm just gonna
give that a quick little little saute
and the oil if you want to grab the
garlic throw that bad boy you every
little bit we do we need every little
piece of garlic happy yeah
cumin I love cominius one of my favorite
events and this is herbs de Provence oh
this is also one of my yeah so good base
blends smells like frogs smells like
rose have you been to France yes I've
been to from yes I grew up right near
frogs
where'd you go out in Germany I did not
know that
border it's so close fun facts about
Candice if you want to check grab some
of the yam you can just start to like
strip them a little sexy time bow chicka
one time all right so that's two and
good we're gonna put in our sorry
our parsnip I always forget about
parsnips I know they're like The
Forgotten veg definitely so now let's
throw the the system vegetable stock
throw that bad boy in why do I smell
everything it's just the way that I
consume food I just smell it smell it
first well anything with garlic and
onion is not really good listen times if
there's like a funky smell in my condo
I'll just cook up something yeah yeah I
can I know I hear you girl that's that
gives X anything everybody wants their
hair to smell like garlic yes yes
definitely
odo de onion all right so I'm gonna pop
a lid on and let this kind of get
bubbling awake so we got to get those
parsnips nice and sausage so that'll
just take a few hot seconds and we will
meet you on the flip side
all right so Candace we are rockin and
rollin and getting a nice you facial
delicious mmm
nothing like a good winter soup facial
you don't have to respond no
diversability for sure alright so I'm
going to take most of our roasted
chickpeas and cauliflower the rest I'm
gonna save for garnish we're gonna pop
them guys in get in there a little a
little devils alright perfect Locker
swap it out alright
all right so let's just pop the lid back
on let it go just a little bit longer
till everyone's soft then people puree
oh wow so now and add some of this
beautiful coconut milk this is one of my
favorite soup ingredients of course it
just eyes that like creamy factor and
just makes it insulate more luxurious
we're all about luxury oh yes yes
yeah we are highbrow here in Abby's
kitchen look at miracles new creation
those dolls
alright now I will say you may want to
stand back this is where things get
dangerous folks okay folks all right it
looks good hmm I'm gonna just add a
little bit of salt a little bit of
soccer I throw them in there Oh
oh yeah it's [ __ ] bubbling it's doing
it's like we're living tarting thing
it's a little aggressive and the salt
and pepper is related to oh really okay
and now of course I'll meet you there
eyes first a little garnish so I like to
put it like just around the side kind of
thing and if you and I like there
exactly there you got it
it looks so good and that a little this
is beautiful right
[Music]
that is delicious thanks Candace hmm
times
that's really nice coming from a you
know such a a vegan superstar right here
stop it I'm really excited but you have
to say the crunchiness of the garnish is
my favorite part so it's a bit like
texture Balint back rub
mm-hmm I am super excited to try your
recipe so we definitely are going to
finish up our little soup here but then
you have to check out Candace's recipe
for pumpkin sage soup
from her new cookbook edgy veg so we are
going to just eat this right now but if
you loved this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up spoon up to leave your
comment below some of your favorite
vegan soup ideas subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen
[Music]